[Música]
hoy miércoles 20 de abril es un día
crucial en francia ya que ambos
candidatos para la presidencia hablamos
de manuel macro ni marín le pen se
enfrentarán en un nuevo debate que será
visto por millones de personas en
televisión nacional ambos esperan que
esta ocasión no sea similar al debate
del año 2017 que terminó en insultos
macrón admite esta vez que le pen ha
progresado y que hay que desenmascarar
la y también desentrañar su programa de
campaña los últimos sondeos muestran que
el presidente francés y aspirante a la
reelección aventaja a la cantidad
extrema derecha sin embargo el índice de
votantes indecisos se mantiene muy alto
y se esperan que hoy los candidatos se
dirijan entonces a los que en primera
vuelta votaron por el ex candidato ya me
linchan quien anunció hoy que espera
convertirse en primer ministro del país
en el próximo ejecutivo para analizar
entonces lo que va a pasar el día de hoy
en este debate que se espera y qué puede
pasar con estos votantes tan jugosos y
apetecidos por los aspirantes quiero
saludar en ese momento a pierre le pegue
el es internacionalista cooperante
politólogo gracias pierre por estar con
nosotros en este espacio de france24
llamado directo américa también nos
acompaña en nuestra mesa de trabajo rosa
pérez más lo que ha hecho todo el
seguimiento en nuestro programa directo
américa a estas elecciones francesas
buenos días rosa y bien entonces le
pregunto qué esperar sobre este debate a
lo mejor la diferencia que pueda haber
desde el año 2017 recordamos un poco
también a la audiencia que vimos hace
cinco años
mira yo creo que el gran desafío de esta
elección es claramente captar los
votantes de llorís minuto y hace poco
día una gran mayoría de ellos han optado
por el voto blanco voto nulo entonces
hay una atención allí y vamos a ver si
el presidente va a ser capaz de hablarle
al electorado de izquierda lo cual no ha
sabido hacer en estos últimos años y eso
es el gran desafío del presidente
saliente en un presente candidato y
tenemos una candidata que aprendió de su
debate y fallido de hace cinco años
atrás y que está en una posición más
jamás preparada y que claramente vamos a
verificar esto en esta noche buenos días
querían podemos preguntarle que dado que
macro no se mantiene por delante en la
intención de voto y nunca ha sido al
revés que tan determinante puede ser
este cara a cara de cara a los
resultados pues del próximo domingo o si
un poco la victoria ya está escrita
yo creo que
según un último sondeo macro en canarias
por según 54 o 55 por ciento hay una
dinámica a su favor lo hemos visto en
los últimos sondeos lo últimas dos
semanas habla de una victoria del
presidente saliente
pero por el margen de votante indeciso
que existen todavía y que se supone que
con este debate van a ayuda a ayudar a
definir esta dirección aún así hay mucha
gente que no lo están decidiendo votar
ni por uno ni por otro y que presionará
atenerse no entonces yo creo que hay
posibilidad quizás que sea un poco más
estrecho al margen de lo que se anuncia
en estos últimos se encuentra y
precisamente qué teclas podrían tocar
cada uno de los candidatos para
convencer a este electorado indeciso yo
creo que lo que lo que va a pasar esta
noche es que de manera macro claramente
va a tener que desenmascarar finalmente
la candidata que cambió y que mutó en su
imagen en esta campaña presidencial
en un punto que va a tocar marín dope en
contra el candidato macro no es el tema
de la reforma de la jubilación que es un
punto muy impopular aquí en tanto la
reforma de la jubilación que ha sido
propuesta por matrona los 65 años va a
ser un punto de debate muy fuerte esta
noche yo creo
y que por supuesto de manera macro va a
tener que
precisar y profundizar en el anuncio de
las posibles negociaciones que podrían
haber con los partidos de izquierda para
que no sean 65 años sino que un poco
menos con alguna cláusula pero eso va a
ser un punto bastante importante del
debate así espiar y es que el presidente
candidato macrón hablaba como usted
también lo decía de desenmascarar y
desentrañar este plan de campaña y
precisar algunos puntos que es lo que
tiene que precisar el presidente macro
para rebatirle estos puntos de campaña
de marín le pen y qué es lo que tiene
que desenmascarar digamos
hay un tema de internacional de todas
maneras estamos en un conflicto justo
graña en europa y por supuesto la
cercanía de marie le pen computing es un
es un tema que no será tocado desde la
parte de las relaciones internacionales
y otro punto es la relación con europa
que sabemos muy bien que marín diop en
sus alianzas son diferentes su visión de
europa es muy diferente también de
manera fronto sí yo creo que el
candidato presidente va a tratar de
demostrar que por un lado están los
nacionalistas por un lado él está con
europa entonces eso es un punto yo creo
que las redes y nacionales esta vez en
esa campaña presidencial por el contexto
geopolítico a tomar un lugar central en
la campaña presidencial de este año muy
distinto ha sido las últimas
presidenciales claro y por otro lado
marín le pen que puntos puede atacar del
balance del mandato presidencial de
manuel macro na parte de la reforma de
las pensiones es tan impopular como
usted mismo ha dicho que otros puntos
puede usar marie le pen para capitalizar
el descontento con emanuel macro
quizás hay una imagen del presidente
marrón que no le ha dejado que es que lo
llaman el presidente de la élite el
presidente de los ricos el tema del
impuesto sobre la fortuna que él le sacó
en durante su mandato el tema también de
bueno claro de la reforma de las
jubilaciones de su visión también poco
dialogante por ejemplo tuvimos la crisis
del chaleco amarillo
el presidente organizó grandes debates
nacionales sobre sobre el tema de cómo
responder a la crisis del chaleco
amarillo sin embargo esto no quedó en
casi nada entonces hay un descontento en
el país todavía y ese descontento ella
logra captarlo entonces yo creo que eso
también lo va a instalarnos la falta de
respuesta frente al movimiento del
derrochar eco amarilla ahora pierre
también gustado hablado un punto muy
importante por supuesto en el contexto
internacional en la geopolítica y es lo
que está ocurriendo en un gran en la
invasión rusa y ucrania recordemos que
la candidata de la derecha marine le pen
dijo que de ganar sacaría a francia del
mando integrado de esta alianza
trasatlántica además de un acercamiento
con rusia estas declaraciones que tanto
favorecer o jugar en contra al epen
hay un punto también que ya señaló que
ya iba a neutralizar más bien retirar
todo el tema de la cooperación militar
con alemania
recordamos que alemania y francia es un
poco el núcleo de la unión europea es el
motor de esa alianza franco-alemana es
uno de los motores de la unión europea
entonces cuando hay una candidata a la
elección presidencial francesa que toca
ese punto tan importante en la relación
internacionales del país en el país de
francia
creo que claro eso es un punto que el
presidente marrón va a poder usar a su
favor y más bien para demostrar la
visión quizás
no sé si peligrosa pero la visión
que él además sería muy difícil de
aplicar porque tendría que tener una
mayoría parlamentaria
bastante fuerte para poder aplicar lo
que ella dice respecto de las recientes
nacionales de del país claro y que va a
pasar también con los europeístas este
voto recordamos también que la cantidad
ha dicho que no tiene la intención de
sacar a francia de la unión europea pero
sí que prime el derecho y las leyes
francesas sobre la unión europea y
recordemos estos países como polonia y
como también pues hungría que han tenido
estos choques con el bloque comunitario
por decir que su derecho prima sobre el
bloque comunitario cuando en verdad el
pacto europeísta digamos que dice lo
contrario
y así está así yo creo que sus alianzas
y ella sale victoriosa de esta elección
sus alianzas las alianzas de plan se van
a cambiar ella había hungría y polonia
como posibles aliados más fuertes de su
presidencia pero la verdad es que eso
debilitaría la unión europea y respecto
a muchos temas también el tema de su
psuv ella logró mutar su imagen en esta
elección en esta campaña pero su
programa sigue igual de radical ella va
a beneficiarse de los votos desde muchos
que sabemos que era mucho más radical
que ella pero ella
se va a beneficiar de esos votos pero su
programa sigue igual de radical cuando
en política exterior como el tema
interno sobre el tema inmigración
hay personas que dicen que no van a
votar que van a votar para para macro no
tanto para ellos sino que para apoyar a
los migrantes que me imagino está en una
situación esta semana muy tensa debe
saber cuál resultado va a ser este
domingo y precisamente por este tema no
de la migración que comenta cuáles son a
día de hoy las políticas que diferencian
a ambos candidatos en el tema migratorio
securitario porque durante el mandato de
manuel macrón también hemos visto
imágenes de mucha violencia contra
personas migrantes en cale o en las
afueras de parís y también una de las
críticas a macro cne es que ha comprado
el discurso identitario de la extrema
derecha que que les ha mantienen o que
les diferencia todavía
es un tiene mucha razón en lo que dice
yo creo que hay una parte de la clase
política francesa que ha tratado de ir
hacia las ideas de la extrema derecha
para poder captar votos finalmente no
pero claramente hay diferencias hay
diferencias en términos de principios
han tenido respeto de las diversas
declaraciones
internacionales que nuestro país ha
firmado en protección de la infancia
cuando los menores inmigrantes llegan en
territorio francés bueno más
independicemos ellos están por hacer un
retorno forzoso de esas personas de esos
niños pero también están en de favor del
reagrupamiento familiar
entonces allí hay muchas cosas que te
cierren y que se basan también en los
principios de la república francesa
aunque la libertad de guardiola tenía
entonces por supuesto que es un programa
opuesto por supuesto que el manera
macrón también avaladas ya su control de
la migración pero marín depp en su
radicalización sería una violación de
derechos humanos nuestro país
pierre finalmente podemos ver
y ahorita a las 14 horas de bogotá quito
lima y la noche de francia un debate de
altura por parte de los dos candidatos y
dejar atrás los insultos que se vieron
en 2017
yo creo que claramente va a haber una
por la preparación de los de ambos
candidatos el macro no viene con una
política de cinco años que va a tener
que defender plantea los ataques desde
marie le pen y tenemos una candidata que
parece más cercana con la gente que
parece más relajada respecto a ese
debate ya lo ha dicho reconociendo que
su debate anterior fue fallido si
tenemos dos candidatos que van a va a
haber un lugar un choque de propuesta un
choque de programa esperemos que con la
mayor claridad posible
para qué lado indeciso puedan definir su
voto de cara al domingo para que la
extensión no sea tan fuerte como lo
anunciaron